you're not going to get psychological
depth
anywhere else in the hebrew bible the
way in which you get it here in the
david's story
the david's story confronts us with
those huge questions of life itself what
is man's relationship to god what is
man's relationship to his fellow man
what is a parent's relationship to their
children
we understand all of this when we see
david there
with the death of his child and knowing
he's fully responsible for all of this
it is the horror of each one of his
children david knows that it always goes
back to him
human beings will not always do what we
ought to do the solution is simple one
repents i think this is what david has
learned and my goodness that's not a
failure i would say that's precisely
what makes david a hero
i would be delighted if you would join
me as we go through and look at the
david's story here to see the tragedy of
saul
see how confused a man that he is
see both how obedient and simultaneously
disobedient he is to join me as we look
at david
a man who misuses his kingship and then
somehow even in the face of disaster he
finds his way out of it he repents and
he turns back to god
we'll be on that floor with david as
he's weeping tears for a child that's
going to die and then in the stunning
moment when he finds out that he's dead
he gets up and he can then be able to
say
he's not coming back to me
rather i am going to him
[Music]
what does this mean in what ways does
this mark out the rest of the disasters
of david's life
what it will offer to us is not a sense
of who david was historically
i think it's supposed to be asking us
what are you as a human person
i'm justin jackson professor of english
at hillsdale college
this is our course on the david story
let's begin
you